[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
all right and we are live
yo
this is tradition right now we're at pax
east we have the lords
wickedgoodgaminglordsgaming.net 108
dragons tv in the building back in a
convention packs east it's good to be
back y'all it's good to be back real
good to be back surreal it's so real
it's so real it's so real but we're all
here chris where are you
you're all here chris chris great you
can come out now
get copyright structure that's a whole
that's a whole other battle we don't
want to revisit but we're live from pax
east 2022
once again
uh you know we have illustrious
guests every single week and this week
is no different actually it is different
because we have like a half a dozen
tour bus
we have a whole i mean this is this is
the easily the most guest probably
hopefully the most we'll ever have but
uh we uh illustrious guests every single
week back live direct episode 282 of not
another gaming podcast a very special
head-to-head
double header edition iron lords podcast
we're in the realm you're back once
again live and direct with the most
beautiful sensual you know electric
notorious gaming podcasts
plural
on these internet streets when al gore
was thinking about inventing the
internet and was coming up with a
concept for this is exactly what he had
in mind and once again like i said we
have illustrious guests every week and
this week is no different we're live
right upstairs at pax east 2022 and we
had to we had to like evict
once again from across the realms and
beyond from new york and beyond by the
entire
hopefully at least the majority of the
iron lords podcast family uh lord addict
lord sovereign lord snowdough we've got
gene where's jeans there is jeans here
that's lord jean lord jean lord king
108 dragons tv and of course
of course
my cross universe family one of the most
electric podcast hosts in the game lord
cognito how the [ __ ] is everybody
failing today man
but see yeah okay first of all you
[ __ ] up jean's name
all right because gene's name is magic
gene all right
all right you gotta break the bottle to
get
level of podcast this sunday for you
guys
you heard the f-bomb already
this is not sunday this is not something
second of all
second of all this is not you know for
you guys this is for the patreon dudes
y'all get that little extra spoiler
whoever writes the least amount of blogs
uh this week you guys have to go through
and bleep out all the squares that's
your punishment for the lack of
productivity
it's gonna be like two minutes of
content
uh and of course joined by uh our very
own dr bob uh as well myself and bob
we're here chris cannot be here with us
uh which i know comes as a surprise to
me
right many long time listeners but he's
got he's got his own uh bag chasing
going on right now so uh but we'll get
you we'll just get right into it um we
normally start off the show with a
little weekend recap but we're in the
midst of the weekend right now uh if
you're listening and ask us on sunday
ask us on yeah don't even ask me
anything on sunday i'm going to be 20
pina coladas deep
floating face down in the pool of mexico
so i'm still interested
and
uh so if you're listening to this on
friday uh this is the pre-recorded uh
version from you know the week prior
with paxy so we'll throw a couple
interviews in here maybe
um but i guess we'll just go around the
horn i mean you know love to hear what
you guys are looking at at the show like
what you guys have seen so far i know
with day two technically it's day one
for us but uh yeah what any highlights
from the show you know anything standing
out right now
what you're doing so today we did we
talked to uh
four different devs over at apogee games
the publisher at apogee and i mean we
saw four games three of which were built
in unity and all looked totally
different like you you used to be the
like the butt of so many jokes
it used to look like roblox yeah yeah
and now it's so robust like we saw we
saw one game with zomkin which is what
was it called dead
i can't remember the name now dead fury
dead fury right so that was a zombie
game it's kind of it takes the horde
mode aspects of like days gone and just
kind of turned it up to 10. i i i i
didn't think i saw days gone because
days gone looked a little bit where did
it what i did
we didn't see a horde yet yeah but yeah
exactly
what i did see was what was that
microsoft game on the launch title um
it looked it looked like a cleaner state
of decay okay and
and the developer wait a second you're
telling me an indie dev
was a cleaner version yeah xbox product
yeah yeah
during this whole interview this whole
podcast this whole situation
that uh
we are definitely the same person in
different skins he's white i'm black
yeah that's right this is the audio
podcast check it out so i'm giving it to
you so you can hear it and feel it pause
um but also
he's playstation and i'm excited
me too right right
but the last time i saw you
the last time i saw you
what was said
was halo would be out before god of war
you told me
but what you said was 45 what you said
was
halo was never gonna come out i got
hijacked
but the best part about it is it's still
in playable beta
and your joint got question marks around
it
yes so anyway so the state of decay game
looks really good
the developer has um
yeah exactly hell yeah
he has a background as a director in
movies and stuff like that so
the cinematography in the game as far as
the game
looks
lighting and everything
this guy has only been a developer for
three years
wow the game looks incredible
and he did a wonderful wonderful but
there's no isn't much of a horde
at this point so you know again i don't
know if his aspirations are going to be
reached but i mean the dude the game
looks absolutely gorgeous and again
unity and we saw one called below the
stone which is more of like it's it's a
little bit of like startle valley of um
steampunk uh steamworld dig stuff like
that so kind of like roguelike sort of
metroidvania sort of stuff um but with
like crafting and all this sort of stuff
so it looked very cool um then we saw
turbo overkill yes
yes
so i mean again if we you love if you
love doom if you love quake unreal games
like that that is that is that and
taking to the again the next level
because again you look at it and it's uh
it's it's old sensibilities but you know
it's a brand new game right right and
what's the last one oh element element
was the last game that we saw and that
reminded me everybody i'm telling you
this now is when you're really starting
to see the breath of the wild influence
when people are like uh it's four or
five years removed yeah the games that
people when people saw brother i was
like i have to make something like that
right and that was this this game looked
like breath of the wild with a mixture
of cameo back in the day xbox 360. rpg
yeah yeah don't get me started
wait what's the subtext what's going on
what's going on so the sub the subtext
is also i'm going to need to just use
your audio because this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
up all the way
what's not an rpg i'm just going to stop
cameo elements of power is not an rpg
so we confirmed not but
no so we yeah so we play a game called
uh zoltan bob's guess my game and so
basically it's like 20 questions and you
have to guess the game at the end of it
so one of the questions was is this a
role-playing game and he said yes which
threw me completely off and i didn't get
it it was like the first time we did it
also this is way better now i can
actually see you guys uh so it was the
first time we ever did it and i was like
what the [ __ ] well it's not an rpg
he's like yes it is i mean it's like a
platform like action platform
there's no rpg elements in it and then
he was like looking at the wikipedia
before he's like i guess that doesn't
really say anything about him
so that was good an asterisk on it but
uh aka he went there to prove you wrong
no it's not going with me it's a
cooperative game
see at least he admitted i know people
that
for someone who's been wrong a
single-digit amount of times in their
life there we go
would you say you like 97
right all the time i say 99. there we go
that's what i'm talking about
i mean again the stuff that we saw
together like wrestle quest
we saw a boxing manager like the
original boxing manager
championship boxing manager was like a
90s pc okay
and they decided to bring it back and
they're gonna bring it to pc they're
going to bring it to all platforms
i thought the fact that even this was
just good that's a good console they
should have it on switzerland
you see them too right yeah
i thought the fact that they called that
professional boxing manager too was a
bit i thought it was a joke yeah right
there there's a real one there's a real
way it was one oh there's part one yeah
one 1999 it would have worked there's a
bit too because it's like
what game is this yeah and i remember
playing boxing manager back in the day
he played it 1999. wow yeah everything
is crazy yeah
it was a little known
together but uh i'm just happy to be
back yes
just to see people at the devs the guys
at apogee every single dev was so happy
to see us and they
sat us down and around take what they
came in and played
we said we're gonna record three minutes
and every everyone was like at least
seven eight yeah yeah
i don't think i've gone like under 15
minutes like talking because we just
shoot the [ __ ] and like we just kind of
go back and forth and they love that and
they love especially from us because
again
the fans go when they see it and it's
like
they talk to them they want to play the
games they're excited about the games
but the conversation isn't the same
right right we're going we talked to
them and they're like you know
miss you guys we haven't seen you guys
like a lot of these guys saw it playing
nyc yeah we saw them even that they
whatever the last packs was and the gate
is now coming to fruition right so man
it's just fun to be back man and to meet
these two my friend
but it's funny because the inside joke
between wicked good and iop is that
either soft can never make it yeah or
christian never make it so these two
have literally not been we've been here
like mad taxes and it always works out
that one or the other is not just for
some reason or another yeah and we said
driving here well riding the bus oh the
the train the train train i'm sorry um
we can't wait
for them to meet yeah i'm on manchester
city i know bob's gonna be there i know
bob is gonna be i'll be there i'll be
here today and that's it yeah you see
but i know he's going to be there i know
dom is going to be there but then
chris yeah they're going to be good
they're going to meet the world's going
to implode
one of those things like you're walking
on the opposite side of the street one
day and you look over and you're like
what the [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah
like the end of like the dark knight
rises
and he was like just like yeah
um but yeah no we uh i think chris is
going to try to make it to the aso party
tomorrow night so if that happens then
the entire night the world will blow up
it flows in on itself then well we'll
see the dance floor that's right
from new york and i said yeah
he had to move yo he put the doggy on
him
yes they play heads hot killers
they got
it's like theater district it's kind of
cool
is it not a oh it's a royale this year
yeah always a different look is it a
different place i think so yeah i think
royale is a lot better than that i think
the other place i can't remember where
the place was there fenway but i know i
don't
know
okay so that was like two times ago i
think that was that was when we first
met yeah that was yeah yes okay all
right that makes a lot that makes a lot
more sense
that's when they name ring bells when we
walked up to the you know who the hell
we are
do you know who we are
good gaming yeah yeah and she was like
oh yeah yeah let him do let him throw
him because the young people the young
chicken no
she didn't know but the older chick yeah
what are you what's wrong with you yeah
yeah
yeah right there
i'm so glad because i feel like i'm like
a like an [ __ ] when i tell that story
or like you know i like mom it's a true
story
we were talking to one of our buddies
early and we were telling that exact
story and i was like and i guarantee
that they remember it the exact same way
yeah we were standing right there and
they were like oh it's a wicked game
yeah they're good so what are they doing
they're wrong
here they're cold yeah yeah
he was like you know who we are she
probably i don't but that sounds like
some something like that
the young chick tried to shut it down
like yeah
okay this is how he got the name magic
gene all right oh yeah now now get this
part get this part
he's at some weird party
i'm with the polish dude
that's
was it the scum guy not the scum guys it
was um
who's the company i know there was a ton
of
it looked like tumbleweeds was in there
right when we looked because he said he
showed the picture and he's like we were
like and we showed them a picture where
we were oh yeah almost like if you went
to a vfw after a funeral service to like
get yeah like you've done that
like oh my god and they're just playing
like a projector where they're playing
trailers of the games and i take a
picture just like no nobody there but
all the polish deaths and like it's like
a weird prom vibe where everyone's kind
of sitting in their own corner or
drinking themselves take one picture so
instead of guys
[ __ ] stop it yeah we're winning
we were taking pictures all week
we get free food and free drinks this is
the free food free drinks
so we told him
and i swear to god i had two drinks and
then i turned around he was there he was
there now get this point i remember this
is the part where magic gene was there
you guys got in off of the the strength
of you know who the hell he is
how the hell did he get past security
that's what i want that fast get
upstairs get inside and he turned around
he had the jean jacket then you know the
two jacket on yes oh he said yeah pass
me the drink what's up
there was a crazy line to get in but the
media line was gone because that you
guys had started that that early media
hour so i got an uber it was like a mile
away we just a mile a mile or two away
and we went down and we went up the
stairs and uh got through the
check it's it'd be you know he's gone
you know that's when you're lying right
you stumble over your
and everyone in the line to get in was
like who are you why are you cutting the
line
i think they skipped a lot of their own
party because there was like nobody
there that's correct i specifically
remember because look because he was
over the top
i don't [ __ ] remember a lot of it but
i remember because i interviewed with
them earlier that day and they were like
i remember you and i was like those were
the skulls
there was another [ __ ] another i know
exactly
another uh
polish company i don't remember who else
it was i was i was at night there was a
lot of stuff going on
a lot that was classic that's what we
knew from a from a boston party
standpoint for going to e3
boston hit different right it's just to
this day like i tell people i was like
the e3 is cute that's cute what y'all
doing that's cute
here it is
east coast
is in the house
england we never once went to e3 dude i
used to come
i i went to bentley okay cool okay i'll
come in
so the week before exams you come into
harvard square sorry
harvard had freaking parties and my tea
hat party
oh and it was open bar for any of the
schools to come in didn't have to be
from that school yeah
there was a lot of two open bars for
like four hours
it was it was just disgusting
dude austin because it's a college town
so
the people that they graduate it's their
boston it's still you're still in there
you're still in there
yep
is that we uh we i've seen a lot of uh
cool like organizations like gaming orgs
here not just devs uh but we saw we
spoke to two different uh orgs already
today uh one of them was
uh oh my god i'm already i'm blank on
the name it was um cope which is a
coalition of parents uh in esports
so they're focused on
um
resources and like uh assistance and
like kind of a community of parents who
have children in professional esports
orgs or like are pursuing a career in
esports or something like that to help
them with you know like how do i help my
kid like how do i you know help nurture
this and not have it be like a stigma of
like you know oh yeah you know the the
dad was a uh he's the father of a
fortnight pro and he's like you know my
son's 13. and so we met
like a year ago i met a bunch of other
dads at like the fortnite world cup i
met his kid a year ago
yeah he probably did though this is your
kid that's like
i can't talk to you when is that when
bobby boucher's dad shows up at the end
don't be stupid take the money
but no i asked about that i was like so
we've seen some really bad examples of
like fathers in sports like you know
bobby boucher's dad
and i was like and then you look at like
tiger woods and his son i i was sorry i
said
i was like there's two there's a bad
example like tiger woods and his dad and
then there's a good example like tiger
woods and his son because they like play
together and like you could you could
tell that they're like locked in
and i was like you know asking about who
he idolizes and like sports and you know
father-son relationships he was talking
about ken griffey jr
for example and like but yeah he said
that they uh even like their net through
their network had like lawyers and like
financial experts and stuff who would
help parents like set up trusts or like
so they don't mismanage the kids
so don't be like you know really old
later yeah i was nice before yeah right
i'm broke now it's nice when i was 12.
fortnite world cup
2010
yeah and if you catch them young and
they have nobody guiding them
that kind of sounded crazy
if you catch them your contacts
nobody died in them
all right
he said that or you thought
hey hey he said a van okay did you miss
that
you know he was playing games with his
son and he was like you know it's like
we were he was like we were trying to we
tried out all kinds of sports we did
baseball hockey uh basketball and he was
like he wasn't really that great at all
of them but he was really good at
fortnight and cod and halo
i was like that was brutal and he was
like i mean you know he sucked at
baseball awful songs
he put him through him under the bus
like crazy i was like what what if he
does suck but he's not he was like my
kid don't do none of us but he
definitely is good at fortnight yeah he
gets pissed off at me because i suck
like i'm stuck
but he was like yeah i mean so we would
you know we grew up the first couple
years of like him really kind of
reaching adolescence like we were
throwing a ball around that's a water
please now we're playing fortnite and
cod and halo together and like
things yeah i'm like is he carrying you
when you was like i was like i'd be
having him do the same thing two places
you did that last time
but we also talked to uh
this woman rebecca from the game hers
which is uh
yeah and the what i really liked about
their
whole mission is that you know obviously
there's lots of advocacy and a need for
that and for like women in the space who
have encountered you know like terrible
situations or whatnot but they're also
but the real focus is to highlight the
positive
stuff that women have brought to the
gaming industry and like you know women
devs or like you know women podcasters
or content creators streamers and she
was like you know there's so many orgs
out there already that will like help
advocate and like amplify voices who
have been like wronged in gaming like we
want to talk about like the positive
message
well not the girls on twitch we do well
i don't know we talked about uh but she
was talking about like you know how to
how to focus on
like the
like the uh success stories and stuff
like that and help like set up
mentorship and stuff like that so
um
that was really cool and yeah i mean we
i've talked to we did wrestle quest
wrestle quest was great was great and
then midway through the interview the
dude who does the voice of uh muchacho
man or something like that somebody
coming and cutting a promo on me i was
like what are they doing
right yeah yeah nice yeah he does all
the voices yo that was the highlight for
us too because we get over there and i
know about the game because we knew from
nintendo direct it got a good reception
right so we're like all right cool we
knew about it now i'm thinking okay just
for me and you know solve this in the
cut joint
wrestling but which is jrp spin we get
over there the devs i think out of um
there's a mega cat
he passed out of pittsburgh shout out to
pittsburgh super passionate he's like yo
we're going to mix arduin with the
classic old school wrestling field then
like the the aspect of jrpg because like
wrestling games have good storylines
he's like why don't people take
advantage of it so he's talking about
that then he's talking about the action
figure aspect so we're doing all this we
get in our bag petey's rocking and it's
like
double j jeff jarrod just pulls up
i'm like yo
jared yeah for real for real yeah and
he's like he's just in the middle of the
interview and it was just on fire and
then he's like sounds like we're going i
guess he's really promoting the project
yes and he's in there he's a part of it
he helped out with it so while i'm
interviewing him on his role she's like
who you want me or double j so he just
cuts the promo and he's double james and
i'm like yo it was it was wide i'm
sitting there i'm like these are those
moments it's like people understand like
for going to a game of tradition you
just have these random pockets of things
that are happening you got the devs and
you can see like they are happy to be
back
they are happy to be back it's cool they
are appreciative whether we're doing the
mass thing or not they like we outside
come see the game just have to have the
opportunity to get in front of people in
person in person again and for people
who haven't gone that's what we want to
wait we're just talking that's the
difference no disrespect to e3 because
we know that's the super bowl we know
what it is
but isn't it they're getting cancelled
back in the day
but it's a difference it's not taxi
i've always said e3's like incorporates
the colossals of the industry and this
is like the community fact it's it's
it's the smaller people some of the
bigger people show up not me yeah
usually there's like a couple like
middle like you know i mean it's a lot
of aaa
stuff but like in a smaller capacity i
saw the [ __ ] bioware booth and i was
like oh [ __ ] is that bioware
i poked my head over and it says bioware
store
the crazy part is like without pax east
you know you don't get the nurturing of
all these devs that go up to work for
these other people right yeah yeah and
you never know you know who you keep in
touch with and stuff like that that's
the huge difference yeah i say it's
you know
e3 is a super bowl but we really know
like what's in that bowl right now yeah
they they made themselves to it so they
already know who the juggernaut is going
to be playing in there but this is like
the playoffs yeah and everybody's
scrapping yeah you know and then when
you're down there talking to the devs
the passion like the passion that you
get because you can see the stuff
everybody's
looking for somebody's uh views to look
at it right so when you walk up to them
they give you that energy
that you get it's yes you get that vibe
you start the hit sovereign was on
three
interviews back to back and and one way
dragon can attest to this
each one of those devs
brought energy and passion to each
project
and
to and to be in the under one house
was amazing to see
because they were humble they was like
thank you for being here from from the
manager
to
to the ceo
to each developer the passion was it in
that group and you could tell from the
games and from the
developers was incredible
it was very catering yeah yeah that's
why like you know when they were kept
going over the intercom well put your
mask on like look man i don't want to
wear this mask it's like but i don't
want the these
like if we do right now we can go to
more events later yeah
yeah and i think the real thing is is
that this is the first year
that we are at pax
and there's no sony
there's no microsoft
no nintendo there's no super big
you know aaa companies that are here
so it's all those people that are like
passionate about their games and they
want to be here because they want to
show us the game
yeah sailing above them is just
skyrocketing it upwards yes and i think
that was a beaut this is a beautiful
thing you give yourself that personality
from that indie developer company that
that comes at you with that type of
energy when you don't have that
microsoft nintendo sony
everything that they do is an idea that
five years down the line a triple-a yeah
yeah and i do want to point out like you
know talking all the pauses like one
thing i'm just tired of that me and carl
were talking about is like these people
are not doing these dev things and
it's just like look like i get it
cost wise there's some of these
developers that can't come for
restrictions but if you can get a
developer there why are you sending pr
people like yeah it's the difference
between a pr person we had a couple
people that kind of knew what they're
talking about then we had some that had
absolutely none but it's just like it's
a domino effect because if you don't get
these people in here that properly
introduce your game to the press and
then the press properly introduces your
game to to the public then you can't
[ __ ] that you have a failed game like
absolutely yeah that's that's important
and i think i mean
when it comes down to it it could be
generalizing but like there might be
developers who don't have those like
they can't really like get up on you
know and to conduct an interview like
they might not have that and maybe some
maybe some of these smaller developers
are playing it safe and being like we
have to hire a pr firm because we don't
want to [ __ ] up we're not first on the
first one back yeah we're going to first
like we don't want to [ __ ] up so we got
to hire this pr firm and
who knows i mean i actually i had
actually
i think everybody i spoke to today said
we have a pr person and we have the
developer who do you want to talk to and
i was like oh they were i'm the pr
person but like the let me get the dev
yeah they were like the dev will be back
in like 20 minutes
and i was like i'll be back i'll just
i'll circle back around yeah and it's
like i get that but it's like even if
you hire a pr team like at this point
you need to be more selective because
there's a difference we went to some pr
team that's just like i don't know what
this is like literally we happen to
direct the whole interview well the
thing is in in in defense of the
majority i would say there was a
percentage that was that where the pr
person was like okay i don't really know
about this kind of thing and sometimes
okay i don't want to put you on the spot
yeah yeah we waiting for somebody else
yeah but
yeah but to circle back to the games
that's on the floor that that everybody
is uh
looking after and it's two games
and pretty much probably these are the
games that i probably you know me and
gene probably like the most um
on the shoulder of giants yes and cult
of the lamb playing with okay
are those bolts of oliver or
no
the lamb is
on the shoulder of giants i thought
it has great potential yeah
for
marketing as toys
saturday morning cartoons
you hit that wavelength yeah before
launch yeah that game scores a little
frog
on the top of the map and i was talking
to the devil
marlon was playing that and so we're
just standing there the death came up
was like hey we've seen you guys before
like yeah it's like
we interviewed you guys for the second
time yesterday
and then you you guys spoke to our team
also at uh playing with nyc yeah and so
he was just like oh i just love talking
about our podcast you gotta pull up yeah
he was specifically talking about like
i said
the thing with this game is that when
you look at it the conceit of it is
something that's kind of been done
before but what you did is say okay how
do i give this personality what do i do
to give this game personality above and
beyond anything else and we talked about
the frog yep it was like
in the beginning
i talked to the other two guys i was
like what do we do with this character
how about a frog he was like [ __ ] you
and then again but they they created the
character they created story around him
they created something that made you
care about the character at the end of
the day he was like all right let's do
it yeah and that
everybody talks about the frog that's
what they do wrong with the robot you
get it and it is that thing of life yeah
no you're good yeah i told them that i
wanted to see the frog square
yeah
turn him into conqueror right like turn
around yeah yeah the world needs some of
that but he was like it was just one of
those things was like nobody else is
gonna do something right no no yeah i
covered the game at play nyc we did a
big push for them i kind of quietly dm'd
a few people emailed a few people and we
ran into them again today and i said you
know
anything happening with that because as
soon as we walked up then oh you guys
yeah you guys and i was like hey does
anyone reach out about funding and they
are talking to a few publishers yeah
from the stuff that we did that's
fantastic so you know that's a game that
if they get the funding and the money
that's going to be huge like it reminds
me so much of hades it's hades with like
like just like a a platforming charm
right that comes from like almost
frogger or conker
uh kind of crash bandicoot thing it's
just it could be really something
special if they can get a little bit of
money and it looks beautiful at this
point
some money the curious actually cares
about is going away because this is your
first one yeah you know like this is you
you're in the building you know what i
mean media you're going around you're
making it around so like overall for you
like what did this encapsulate how was
pax east overall because you've been to
the e3 you're not like you haven't been
in shows before this is your first pack
so where use that with it let me first
of all be here with y'all that's what
matters first our continuity and how we
give it up meeting guys like this
networking that meant a lot to me but
speaking to the devs on a different
level it's very personal yes yeah it's
very personal i had one dude pr don't
know he took him out
of here you know what i don't know but i
i i ran him through that interview and
made him look like he knew that's what i
had to do for somebody
what i really like is
that personal lineup when you make
when you make your your interview time
yeah and i walk up
i'm a big intimidating dude
and they start pulling out my government
i'm pulling up like you don't have my
picture like hey
so i felt very comfortable
then you know they need a bigger spot
where you going back boom
yo the personal aspect is definitely way
better than the e3 i mean i'm not saying
it's better than e3 because e3
presentation is yeah but now you're
getting it yeah
but i'm talking about the personal
aspect and i also
mingle with the with the community not
just the depths yes and you know they
see me and i'm talking you know i get
i'm yeah
dude who are you
just to get that person that that
personal feel
is is better yeah
like play new york you know
i'm
some dude has some type of game i don't
know what it was it was like a karaoke
open mic everybody could talk game show
game
and the corner was lit and i went in
there
you're right
on the floor aspect and
i'd rather talk to the devs
because they show you their passion for
their game and what they've been working
so hard on and what y'all what you
definitely was hitting on like you was
like when you get there you can work the
floor yeah and it's going to be upfront
and personal yeah so i was like and a
lot of them were the fan first yeah
right yes so that's you know besides
just having my brothers with me and
meeting the people that rock with them
or whatever
but it's just like to get that from
everybody yeah it's not like crazy this
person acting funny jeff like you come
on
you know come over here oh yeah yeah
right right right you know they did they
welcome you yeah you know what i'm
saying so what the [ __ ] are you dressed
up as like
what's that
you know a person enthused about our
shirts yeah yeah oh i know who you are i
said no you don't
i just want some ramen noodles
did he come back with a story like yo
johnny said green a favorite clown
snaps like green
quest i think that was fantastic i
thought that was amazing what it's going
to come out to be
um but we saw
something that i was dying to see last
packs
and the development of um
titans of industry and phantom brigade
how they evolved from the last packs to
this packs was huge
and seeing how everything was you know
getting better and better at that i want
to check that out
dude i love the whole mech concept
and the way that they ended up putting
the necks pretty much on a timeline
so like you can have movement and then
what'll end up happening is that the
enemies will have movement at the same
time
so it's like everything happens at once
and you have to time it all and it's
really really interesting
and then having um
how they're that's all evolving and it
seems like it's a very large open
i i'll i'm gonna say open world but i
don't think it's a fully open world uh
situation yet
and seeing that was awesome and then
seeing titan of industry which was this
game that i i saw and i was like
so it's kind of like a sim city
defending kind of like rts i was like
and then and then she saw she says yeah
and then when you um when the ship's
battle it goes right into an ftl i'm
like are you telling me this is like
faster than light i'm like i was just
like i was like on crack
that was awesome i really really liked
it was good nice
look i have emails for every single one
of these games i've been in contact with
these devs for three years at this point
like i know what your game's about you
know i know what your game's about
i played your demos
i'm not here for the games i'm here to
see the people
that i wanted to see the friends of the
community friends
with everybody we want to see
and i'm here to get [ __ ] up on
saturday night
the goal will be accomplished
in the room nobody going to talk about
that damn ninja turtle that's old okay
all right
[Music]
actors from the 1990s cartoons
really i didn't know that one
when they remade turtles in time when
they remade turtles in time they kind of
messed up and they had like three levels
in the whole game
and it was like that just felt felt so
flat i was like such a bummer because
that's one of my favorite games ever
yeah turtles are my favorite games
this feels like one of them it was 3d
yes
yeah but they literally had like one
chapter in the game like it just ended
there but um when i saw the trailer for
that i was like i need to i need way too
late this is a whole new game i asked
him kind of like off the cuff it was
like classic 10 levels 10 bosses kind of
thing and he's like yeah but he wouldn't
commit to exactly how many levels they
were all the levels are designed based
on the 1990s cartoons that's amazing it
comes from different areas that's super
dope you'll probably expect more more
characters yeah especially if it's
especially if it takes off
i saw somebody playing this master
splinter and i was like oh
that was like in april
[Music]
he kept calling the master
but it's okay though but the dad was
cool with it right the dev just you know
corrected him nice and easy
but he didn't say it right then yeah he
said and then you also have to play a
character playable character master
suspension
i had to get the rust off bro like i
don't know about you like
it's a thing when you're moving and
shaking it it's like you know what
you're doing is consistent and you
haven't done anything like we haven't
been in the booth for two years yeah
right so for me i'm like stuff like this
yeah like you know and then also the
energy then remember the mask is on so
you're doing the mic thing so it's a
different vibe and it just took a while
to cook and start warming up for me
though for us there was this little game
it was like 12 players it's called
the pirate game yes it was um
so
we i'm sitting there this would be some
little game for us to start getting fun
whatever whatever so we break them up
get on one side whatever whatever devs
is on one side oh
he wasn't the dude
right so okay so i'm gonna tell them
about the game first of all first of all
i'm gonna keep it a buck yeah
they didn't have the real mvp
y'all keep messing around not knowing
who magic jean is
magic gene excess
the whole thing he listened to the devil
that was talking i'm so sorry that y'all
wasn't paying attention i'm happy to be
there y'all was happy to beat it
what you do when you try to play a game
punish him
so
this is this is this is how i know gene
is doping i will always pick him first
y'all don't look don't stop looking at
the cover he wears the suit jacket for a
reason all right all right so so this
dude he on my team i'm so happy right
now like y'all don't know what's going
on and then we had to do that
so what they did was they queued up
squad up they swallowed it up so i was
like wow
that just threw us to the side all right
me and jamie like all right give us the
two dabs whatever and i'm not gonna
front that dev really didn't know he was
throwing he made the game but he really
didn't know but yeah i'm just being real
uh
so
gene knew very early on you could blow
they join up you can roll a boat over to
blow it up or you can stealing money so
for the record so we we talking to an
audience that does not know what this
game is
break the game
song
explain the games
i'm telling you yeah so if the game is
6v6 we could only play uh four before
they didn't have that ready yet right so
basically there's two ships right and
you have
each character plays a role right you
have a captain you have like the
underlings or whatever you have all
kinds of different characters they have
monkeys and all kinds of stuff right so
the goal is
either to
take all of your opponent's booty take
all of that
cheeks
[Laughter]
or sink their [ __ ]
kill their captain okay sink their ship
through cannon fire or sink their ship
by rowing a robo with full of dynamite
over to the other side
so what happens is
so you have to do is to get weapons
right the captain has a weapon already
right captain starts with a weapon and
he can get double hit if you smack him
his hat come off
the whole job is to smack the coop
because
his attic whole plot was to get me out
the captain i'm the captain now right so
this is what happened right to the point
where it was their whole team versus me
my whole universe
he had 20 kills right it didn't help him
i had gene
all right what was your strategy so this
is the strategy
on that it's like
you focus on the wrong thing
while somebody else is either shooting
you with a cannon across
and then like 30 seconds later i wrote
the i wrote the bombs into your boat and
then yeah
don't play these games so they tried to
cut us off at the ankles right so they
threw us in there
is saying it's more justifiable for them
to remain with two devs than it is for
us to what happened what happened after
so gene found a different way to get
them and what's crazy is gene because
they they they found out about the boat
at the back
they found out they
so this is how gene has this telepathic
power yeah right i'm telling you it's
magic jake so i look over at jean looks
over at me we already spoke
we already spoke words have already been
exchanged
you know and so what he said when he
looked at me is i got another way
and you know what i said
i'll cover you right so he goes i start
running out i'm going straight at attic
right because i know attic is the hitter
yeah he did it right
they king's entire plot was attic out we
so my job was to smack his coffee off
and go get him right so we're doing that
gene is stealing the cash
from the top yeah so now you're worried
about the bottom she ain't even there
jesus up in the side and it's where you
hide it at he got it and then he died
again he said okay now so now they
thought the devil looked over like oh
they really know what they're doing yeah
he's over here talking all the smack
they only won by one
no no no it was fine
no no so we're gonna we're gonna count
by two just okay yeah we
yeah it's so much going on and it's
actually a lot of in-depth mechanics and
we start i think like we'll get our feet
wet with a nice little cute image
and i'm like yo this turned into a thing
yeah i'm like so that was one we got a
show
so to me my personal highlight for them
for the group
who was that fighting game for me
was it like
die by the blade so the game actually
did i ever die
okay this looks cool kind of like a
bushido blade in the future
but very intense but um sword combat
weapon combat okay so we get there we
interviewed that what happened so we
like all right we're gonna let king and
song y'all be the game play whatever so
the dance talk about the game so i'm
hearing him in the background
who what what get your man so i'm like
oh he buying sauce i'm trying all right
cool so we're going through the day when
i was like yeah
another one
so he talked a while so it's oh it has a
lot of one hit kill potential okay
so as it's going on the dev stop she's
like you want me to go no cuz i got
attic too yeah
nobody knows
that work one attitude
i killed before i killed two oh that's
why you came back i don't play these
fighting games because i know i played
it okay and then after he beat me that's
when the death came yeah
the controller but i looked him dead now
i was like kill him
you want me to handle him i'm like no no
he's saying you want me to shut him off
i'm interviewing you
we got a man to stop doing his job
he wasn't feeling king body
body and because his mouth is real loud
everybody's looking around this is like
what's up
30 people so now 30 people
and when it started they were called and
they were talking like maybe two or
three people walking by king starts
running his mouth
then the dev gets on key uh get gets
over there and plays king keep in mind
what king and them are playing is on
this screen big screen for everybody to
see after the first game king gets king
gets rocked more and more people sarcoma
there was like 30 people behind this
this was the moment to me
so i said that's all good let me get my
girl that's aerodynamic so now he gets
kicked out of the first draft so
everybody has expected sure yeah yeah
whatever
so now i'm watching the next round king
got the girl character he's got the
samurai character it's very you know
someone's very tactical very very
defensive no one wants to make a move so
now king is starting to chip away oh and
then he gets hit so i go oh it's a king
even guards complete
so the dudes i can tell the tension is
raised
so now actually kick feeding off the
energy
finally cut him down and win the round
i was like if my man can't beat you you
got to make him dlc
so you can see and there's this and all
those casualty well you said he started
mumbling to himself
i hear him he's like i gotta power this
on the line like we are like it is so
funny the attention to the room you
could like it's hilarious and that's
when he finally pulls it off but it was
so much fun just from a fighting
perspective the energy in the room the
game looks phenomenal like yo we had a
fantastic time with that joy i'm not
even going so he ended up so you're not
going to be dlc
but the thing is i would be nightmares
for him
he's going to see you laughing
he really thought he was going to come
over there and handle me yes
and i was putting pressure on him right
you know can you imagine like when peter
mcnealy
ran over to mike tyson
my cocoon yeah
remember that yeah in the first round he
just ran that way it was going crazy and
caught mike everybody's oh [ __ ]
it's kind of crazy so that's i felt like
peter panel it was delicious
mike wound up getting them
and i'm like is it a straight action
game yeah see this is a prequel game to
the right to the main game that's going
to come out yeah the whole there was a
whole lot of exposition we sat there we
were watching it for like a good five
minutes oh no it's action and it's
swapping swap out right
is
the guy that we were interviewing
stopped talking and just watched watched
it was like
asking
and he was like you're saving people
i said yeah yeah yeah that i've never
seen what you want
is anything going to change after you
say he's like oh no you're a citizen but
no i don't do nothing for free what did
i get oh yeah
that was funny but the cool thing i said
going the side scroll in the black and
white that's the samurai i feel from
back in the day the fact that you're
going the foreground to the background
2.5 do you know what i noted
yeah the dudes in the background they
were you know like you know in a bruce
lee film where they they wait to get
bruce lee yeah i just saw them and then
they'll switch out yeah
wanted to take a hit and it was like
hold on let me move back
especially the dudes that come from
the front side of the screen yeah and
they come in running and all the two
steps like my man
that's awesome i'll just say real quick
for you like you'll be making your
rounds what would somebody highlight for
you i spend a lot of time in the
devolver booth now we're talking about
track to you me um
we talked about that but
is
it's like it almost reminds me of
death's door it's a hack and slash
adventure death store is one of my
favorite games but no that's amazing but
it has a base management sim mechanic
into it you're a lamb
oh come on
and for that reason i love games that
mix up mechanics because it's it keeps
it fresh i don't like bass anything
i found i loved fallout 4
until i had to build a [ __ ] bass
then they forced you to you yeah
this is the first one this is in my
[ __ ] back follow for my backyard
and then you're gonna force me to build
something
i need to be fair
to be fair it is an apocalypse world so
you probably try to build something
that's not
otherwise
no i don't i keep saying
yeah that's when you're out
yeah you uh you have a cult and they
they come back to your base and they
have to have jobs like you know build-up
or cold
you play on this huge screen and you sit
on a couch and the colors are great it's
very gothic but you're this cute little
lamb and there's like satanic elements
to it so it's really funny yeah what
else was that devol it reminds me of
gravity falls oh like um
evil spirits
if y'all ever watch gravity falls how is
it's like if you ever watch gravity
falls
it has that same vibe uh
where you have this cult energy that's
inside the game
but the game
visually
uses shades of red like i've never seen
which is kind of crazy right and and
i know on a on lg not a tcl
um
lg oled you know in a dark room
it it will play well because the blacks
in the back is very good visually it's
very stunning when you walk in so yeah
did you play uh jade mcpixel yes
it's like so i explained it what's the
pc game that was like baked into like
every windows 95 pc where you're going
down the hill and the obama snowman's
chasing you oh
what's that oh my god and it always
catches you it's that uh but there's
like a difference
yeah it's like a different scenarios
though there's like different outcomes
he says there's a like a hundred
different outcomes you can have like
it's all pixelated like that like eight
bit and you're in a plane and you can
grab a handle you can grab a cat and
there's a lot of like dick and fart
jokes yeah and you can grab a woman and
like what do you grab like you grab the
handle but the prank is that the you
wouldn't you just like grab the woman
and throw the woman out the train and
then that stops the train you know but
there's stuff like that um did you grab
the um the
the the cat when the cat was looking in
did you grab the matchstick yeah all
right so you're you're trapped you're a
guy in a mouse oh sorry and i'm out in a
little hole in a
like a baseboard in the house and it's a
cheese sometimes
same thing different scenarios each time
so
a slice of cheese a matchstick and a
mouse
if you grab the matchstick you kind of
sneak around the cat it's like a
cutscene and you stick the matchstick up
the cat's butt
then that's the end of the cat and it
and the cat smashes you this yo okay
what's okay let's do this
mcpixel
pixel right
is it like mixpixel
three oh three all right
there's a lot of weirdos wanting to
stick stuff up cat's butts
the devs comes up so he sees how much
fun that we're having
that's an interview that i won because
we had uh like we had 11 o'clock right
then we had to go
but he singularly made the game he's
super by himself
super energetic about this game and all
right to be honest with you in this
devolver digital booth
the fact of the matter is this
for that game to stand out
with cult of the lamb to check the naomi
there was something else it was the
other game it was like a train sim or
something like that tara neal is yeah
that's uh
it's a steam demo so we didn't you know
go too much into it but for that game to
actually even stand on the same level of
it yeah it had a huge amount of comedy
in it and it was very well thought out
and that developer needs to have a shout
out absolutely and real quick too um
video we have to shout out the two
brother team yes x-com cyber cyber night
stealth it was like cyber nights it was
cybernetic
flash points yeah
you play something like that and you
realize like the only thing preventing
these indie developers from overtaking
triple a is money
yeah that's all it is because they had
the xcom field they had a cyberpunk feel
and they had stealth like metal gear in
the game it was in the hostile fire yo
these two dudes they were putting it in
and they they were passionate they loved
you could tell you that that was the
biggest brother team
they come up to you and they sense it
like they would just flow it's different
energy and that's like to me that's what
you can't replicate at an e3 right
that's what i love here dudes be in
there spitting
aaa publishers they don't they don't
want to take any risk you know they just
want to stay the course the indie
publisher and developers they have to
take risks because they have to stand
out yeah right yeah like second match
sticks up cat's asses
the mouse
yeah i mean by and large i mean i think
you know and the weekend's only half
over so i mean i'm looking forward to
seeing some stuff well a lot of the
stuff tomorrow
but uh you know we
like it just it's just great to be back
i think the general consensus is like
great to be back it feels like
uh
it feels like home it feels like you're
normal it feels like yeah yeah but it's
just like leaving we have to put these
back it feels like it feels like a
family reunion honestly like it feels
like you know seeing a lot of people for
the first time in so long um you know
seeing these devs like some that you
recognize some that you don't um you
know and just like having the
opportunity to come out here and do this
again um is just it feels great so
absolutely
i think that's why i get like annoyed
when people like wish death upon like e3
and stuff because it's just like
even if you don't like it why do you
just want it
yeah actually it's twitter
don't go out they don't go outside
it's like it's the coolest thing is we
might say it's horrible this is
[Laughter]
is still a lot of people those are the
dudes that talk crap
and they never twitter and then they see
you in the pitch and they go oh [ __ ] i
ain't no king was that big
you know how many people put
until i left real player one
you know god might have to wear the mask
for a couple more events uh but you know
keep stuff by the book and you know
events and stuff will be accommodating
yeah
let's just be real here they lifted the
mandate we could yeah
this is the comeback
they probably they probably i mean with
pax i mean they probably did the right
they did the right thing
i'm playing it safe
play it extra safe i mean
i don't care how sick that's just played
but i think this proves this this
continues to prove like the fact that
anybody's here yeah proves that this is
there is still a space for this like we
were saying with like e3 and people like
oh good we don't need these things
anymore because we'll just you know
we'll do like summer game fast they'll
play a couple youtube videos for us and
i mean even [ __ ] and market what
eminem's to us yeah yeah right five
minutes
uh that was the game awards where it was
like the game it was the game ads that
was like you know and i don't want that
like i wanted to be there's a room for
stuff like this and this is there's a
reason why you got to come here in
person like the destination or like the
trip is still worth it so
saturday is so loud
that's right
but nobody there was a lot of people
here yeah and that's where people was
like oh why do they have a pack sound
like dude they had the super bowl shut
up
uh so paxis was the last convention for
the bandana and now it's the first one
back yeah that's right it's a great
opening
i've been saying this for what a year
now maybe a little bit more that pax
east will be forever the litmus test for
how things move forward from here events
yeah if this works
hopefully i think we're good yeah if it
works you continue to see uh you know
less restrictions yes things opening up
more you know we're not a third capacity
we're at like 75 percent capacity like
two packs credit
when they heard about everything that
was going to happen the last one that we
were at i know this place was clean
i told everybody you're not getting sick
from this
i think it's
has been a lot of negative
like negative outputs but you know at
the end of it all i think you'll have
events rant better because
you have to follow
all the developers that
[Music]
not another gaming podcast back now i
got a check yeah i think it's too weird
i think there's two anywhere
i think we like 250 episodes xxx 254 the
i mean this is the the
i mean
the biggest episode of the podcast we've
done yet uh thank you guys yeah 282. uh
appreciate all you guys for making some
time i know we got a lot going on this
weekend but uh thank you for joining us
once again it's an honor and a pleasure
and uh yeah i can't wait to tear it up
tomorrow you already know bro i love
podcast again 254 in the building packs
east back 2022 always good to be with
our brethren we have more things to show
you we want to give you a little
something live from the floor we're not
live we're pre-recorded
live-ish
but to give y'all something just to
understand like what it means to come to
these shows
been working with these brothers for a
minute you know i'm saying what's good
it's good lords of gabriel.net in the
building one away dragon in the building
pity in the building saw that all four
is the guy from the xbox
[Music]
you